There's a trade war going
on between America and China
which is dominating global politics
and a lot of that has to do
with more traditional goods
like cars or soy beans.
But actually quite all
of the attention is being
paid to semiconductors as well.
So, semiconductors are a vital ingredient
in computer chips.
They have electrical characteristics
that make the chips work.
If you look in your car
you'll find not just one
but probably dozens of
different computers,
your smart phone obviously in your pocket,
whenever you do anything with your bank
that transaction will almost certainly
be handled electronically.
They're only going to become more common
as computers spread further
and further into modern life.
America is really the dominant player.
Of the top 15 biggest companies
none of them are Chinese.
China does have an industry
but a lot of it is dependent on imports
so semiconductor imports are
actually cost it more than oil.
A lot of what it imports are components
that then go in to finished goods.
So you think of things like your iPhone
which is assembled in China
but all of the designs for the chips
and the chips themselves
come from outside.
Semiconductors are important
really for two reasons.
One is economic and
they underlie huge parts
of the global economy so the
entire E-commerce industry,
for instance, which have revenues
of that two trillion dollars a year,
would be impossible
without semiconductors.
There's also a national security angle.
In America, in particular,
has always seen it's
lead in this technology
as a vital national security asset.
And America's military was
actually one of the earliest
and biggest customers
for Silicon Valley chips.
Even these days armies,
like everything else,
are becoming increasingly digital
and semiconductors are
vital to make that happen.
In order to build up
it's domestic industry,
China's willing to spend a lot of money
so it's established an investment fund
designed to boost the local industry
and that it's capitalized that
with a 150 billion dollars.
It's made semiconductors
one of the priority areas
in it's Made in China 2025 initiative
which is a general attempt
to boost manufacturing
across the country.
America sees semiconductors
as a strategic good
so it's quite worried by China's attempts
to build up a domestic industry.
Earlier this year America
forbade it's companies
from selling chips and
intellectual property to ZTE
which is a Chinese maker of smartphones
and telecom equipment.
And because it's dependent
on American chips
the company was pushed to
the brink of bankruptcy
almost over night and was
only saved at the last minute
when Trump decided to rescind the ban.
The ZTE affair proved two things.
One, was that America's technological lead
translates in to political power.
It can use this lead to
frustrate Chinese ambitions
but it also made it very clear to China
just how dependent their
companies are on American product.
There are several ways
in which America could respond to this.
The first might be to try
and work with it's allies.
Countries like South Korea, Japan, Taiwan
which have big chip manufacturing
industries of their own.
To make sure that China doesn't
get an unnecessary leg up
but also to try and work
to establish standards
so that both sides can start
to trust each others products
a little bit more.
A second idea is innovation,
is to try to push the
cutting edge out further,
to run faster to stay
ahead of China in the race
rather than trying to hobble the Chinese.
But I think the final thing
America should do, as well,
is just to prepare for
a world in which China
is more overpowering in this industry
and does have more of an influence
over the digital economy.
I think it can probably
try to slow China down.
I'm not sure that it
can prevent it entirely
and of course trying to do that
would be quite an aggressive move
that would also do quite a
lot of damage potentially
to a really vital industry
that underpins the entire global economy.